we've already seen that if we take a
whole and in this example the whole is
this entire green circle and if we were
to split it into five equal sections one
two three four five so we've split it
into five equal sections and if we were
to select one of those five equal
sections so let's say we select this
section right over here that we have
selected one-fifth of the whole one out
of the 5 equal sections we could do the
exact same thing on a number line
everything we've been doing so far has
to deal with shapes but we could do the
exact same idea on a number line so let
me draw a number line here so let me
draw it pretty big so we get a sense of
things so go all the way to there and
let's say let's say that this is 0 this
is 1 and this is 2 and of course we
could keep going if we had more space 2
3 4 and and on and on and on and what I
want to do instead of taking a circle
and dividing it into five equal sections
I want to take the section of our number
line between 0 and 1 and divide it into
five equal sections so let me see if I
can do this so so 1 2 3 4 5 that looks
pretty good I'm drawing it as as exact
as I can with my hand but let's just
assume these are five equal sections so
what would happen what would you think
would be a good label for this number
right over here well it's the exact same
idea between 0 & 1 I've traveled 1 out
of the 5 equal sections towards 1 and
actually let me make it a little bit
neater than that make it make the equal
sections look a little bit better 1 2 3
4 5 and what we're thinking about is
this what what should be called this
number here this number is clearly
between 0 & 1 it's clearly closer to 0
and we've gone 1 out of the 5 equal
sections towards 1 well it makes
complete sense that look we had five
equal sections here five equal sections
here and we've traveled one of them
towards one so we should call this
number right over here 1
so when we're talking about the fraction
1/5 it's not just talking about hey what
part of a pizza pie have I eaten or
something like that it's actually this
is actually a number this is a number
and we can actually plot it on the
number line now you might say okay well
that's fair about one-fifth but what
about all these other slashes what
numbers would we call that well we have
we can make the same it's the exact same
idea if up here instead of shading in 1
out of the 5 equal sections if I shaded
in two of the five equal sections then I
wouldn't say this is 1/5 anymore I would
say that this is 2/5 and so if I go to
of the equal sections towards 1 then I
should call this number right over here
I should call this 2/5 and I can keep
going this right over here should be 3 3
over 5 this right over here I've gone
one two three four out of the five
sections towards one so I could call
this 4/5 4/5 and that could keep going I
could call this right over here I've
traveled five out of the equal out of
the 5 equal sections towards five so I
could call this right over here five let
me do that in a red color I could call
this right over here five over five
anyone's any weight but five over five
we've gotten to one and that's exactly
right if I were to shade in five things
over here let me do that a little bit
cleaner if I were to shade in five
that's not the color I want to use if I
were to shade in five things over here
we've already seen that shading in five
things so if this is let me make this a
little bit neater if this is now five
over five or five fifths we've already
seen that this is a whole and over here
if we've traveled five fifths of the way
towards one we've gotten to the whole
one five fifths is the exact same thing
five fifths is the exact same thing as
one it is equal to a whole